I'm David I'll be telling you today
about how we can leverage cryptographic
tools for genome privacy this talk is
based on a lot of joint works with my
adviser Dan as well as computational
biologists here at Stanford so Gil dezer
on Oak RC jaggedy show on this Bergen
Meier as well as biologists at MIT this
is Bonnie burgers group and the student
at un homme show great so the kinds of
problem that we're interested in
exploring in this space is problems like
the following what gene causes a
specific rare disease at first glance it
seems like a purely biology problem so
why is it at a security or privacy
workshop so allow me to explain the
setup is roughly as follows suppose we
have a group of patients who all happen
to have a particular genetic disorder
for this talk take as a concrete example
the case of kabuki syndrome so we have a
group of patients who all happen to have
kabuki syndrome now let me also provide
a little bit of biology background the
human genome consists of about 20,000
protein encoding genes genes are
actually responsible for dictating
specific protein functionalities and
individuals both you and I as well as
these patients in our group have about
200 to 400 of these so-called rare
variants places in their genome that
differ from the canonical reference
human genome so the way that we can
abstractly model it is as follows for
each patient we can associate with them
a gene vector of dimension 20,000 one
component associated with each gene in a
protein encoding genome and each patient
will have a one in a particular position
if they have a rare variant in that gene
and zero otherwise so once we formulated
the problem in this way the task of
identifying a gene that is responsible
for a particular disease is essentially
identifying a gene that has the most
common a varied number of variants
across all of the patients in a disease
group in this concrete example here it
will be gene number two because four out
of the five patients in our disease
group have a rare mutation in that
particular gene well this analysis might
seem very simple it actually tends to
work surprisingly well for a very broad
class of genetic diseases mainly the
class of Mendelian or monogenic diseases
diseases that are caused by a mutation
in a single gene these is either
actually quite common and are estimated
to a to affect up to 10% of the
population
so so far if we want to diagnose
Mendelian diseases it seems very
straightforward all we have to do is
gather up collection of patients who all
happen to have the disease sequence
their genomes and then performed its
analysis where we identify the common
gene however there are some
complications in practice today
patients often live in geographically
diverse areas and because of a focus on
rare diseases any single medical
institution or hospital might only have
one or two patients they don't have
sufficient data to carry out the
analysis needed as a result in order to
perform these computations patients
essentially have to entrust their genome
to some central facility or some trusted
party who will then carry out this
computation today due to patient privacy
concerns as well as legal and regulatory
barriers that exist that prevent for
institutions and facilities from
directly sharing genomic data these
kinds of analyses are actually very
difficult to carry out and for a good
reason
a patient's genome is highly sensitive
and if revealed not only compromises
their own individual privacy but also
the privacy of their relatives and their
next of kin and can open them up to
subsequent fraud or discrimination as
such the natural question that the
biologists came to us with is whether we
can hope you perform these kinds of
computations but alleviate some of these
privacy concerns can we perform these
useful scientific computations but
without getting direct access to the
complete patient genomes of all of the
different individuals here the problem
becomes a cryptographic one and in this
talk I will tell you about how modern
cryptographic tools enable us to address
these scientific challenges using
cryptography we're going to the solution
will look roughly as follows we're going
to first assume that we have access to
two entities that don't oftentimes
collude with one other for instance you
can consider a hospital in the United
States in a hospital in Europe and once
we have these two non colluding entities
it actually becomes much easier to make
progress on this problem what we can do
is something along the following each
patient will take their genome and do
what's called a secret sharing of their
genome and send each share to each of
these two hospitals what this means
concretely is the following each patient
will generate a random vector and send
it to one of the hospitals the random
vector has nothing to do with their
genome and to the other hospital
it was send a difference between a
random vector and their genome so notice
that in from a very strong information
theoretic sense each individual Hospital
learns absolutely no information about
the content of any individual genome of
course together they're able to
reconstruct the full information and
that's what it is going to enable us to
perform useful computations on that data
so in this way all of the patients in
our disease group will contribute and
secret share their data across the two
institutions and after all of the data
has been aggregated what the two
hospitals are going to do is engage in
what's called a cryptographic
multi-party computation protocol or MPC
protocol on upward inputs what is
essentially entails is a message passing
protocol so these two hospitals are
going to exchange a sequence of messages
such that at the end of the protocol
execution what they each of them learned
is basically the top most frequently
occurring variant across all of the
patients in a disease group when we
actually perform these kinds of
computations on actual patient data
we're able to successfully reconstruct
and identify the known cause of the
disease moreover the security and
privacy requirements that we can in
satisfy is that all of the hospitals and
all of the patients only learn these
single or the top two or three variants
that are most common across all of them
they do not learn the other 200 to 400
rare variants that any patient might
have that might serve as a genetic
fingerprint for that patient that all
that information is highly sensitive and
it's kept completely confidential as a
result of these computations our
techniques I describe here actually
pertain our apply our applicable more
broadly to many different scenarios so
I've started by describing one such
scenario where we have at this group of
patients and our goal is to identify a
causal gene that afflict all of these
different patients but we can also
consider other scenarios in a genomic
space where our techniques apply equally
well for instance we might have two
hospitals who want to who might want to
identify to see if they have any
patients with common rare mutations or
rare variants this might allow them to
develop common treatment plans and so
forth to us facilitate the diagnosis and
treatment of complex diseases in other
cases we might have analyses where we
want to find an mutation that appears in
a child but not in any of the patients
again cryptograph
techniques enable us to perform these
kind of useful scientific computations
and again all of these examples might
seem very simple but to showcase that
this is actually a very useful
scientific computation let me emphasize
that using our techniques we were
actually able to discover a previously
unidentified pathological variant and
subsequent tests with biologists at the
Stanford School of Medicine was actually
able to confirm that we actually made a
useful and relevant scientific discovery
so these techniques is deployed and
essentially and significantly improve
the amount of patient privacy we can get
and still facilitate these very useful
scientific computations let me do
briefly say the fewers about the
efficiency of our protocol to simulate
these two non colluding cloud entities
we basically set up once to run an East
Coast and once to run a west coast of
the US and we basically measured the
amount of time and computation needed in
order to run one of these protocols for
identifying a causal gene across a small
disease cohort what you can see is for a
modest number of patients somewhere
between 10 and 100 the our protocol is
quite efficient namely the computation
the end-to-end protocol execution time
basically is under 20 seconds and it
only a modest amount of communication is
needed on the orders of tens of
megabytes let me preface here that for
many cases where we have rare diseases
small disease cohorts is actually
sufficient to perform these analyses in
all of our concrete experiments five to
ten patients was actually sufficient and
for these types of scenarios our
protocols are highly efficient and serve
to make the necessary scientific
discoveries now you might wonder
everything I've talked about so far is
related to rare disease diagnosis but
what if we want to understand the
genetics of cancer or find a genetic
causes are like of calm more common
phenotypes like high blood pressure so
in a subsequent work with folks at MIT
we looked at performing even law much
larger scale analyses to also identify
the genetic causes are more complex
diseases and conditions like high blood
pressure or cancer and so forth nakata
genetic tool is often used here is
what's called a genome-wide Association
studies or G wasa for short and
oftentimes the focus is on identifying
the complex interactions that underlie
things like cancer and other more common
diseases there are many challenges that
arise when we have to extend our
multi-party computation frameworks to
handle a large number of patients and
keys out these more complex and weaker
signals for instance often times we have
to work with upwards of ten thousands to
over a million individuals in order to
actually obtain useful scientific
results we oftentimes have to correct
for population level effects because
when we have millions of individuals and
millions of patients sometimes
deviations could just be caused by ones
ancestry these could cause large
correlations with the disease status but
actually are not actually responsible
for the condition we're exploring so we
have to develop algorithmic techniques
to filter out these kinds of population
level effects and develop them in a way
that's amenable to modern cryptographic
tools I won't have time to go into the
details let me just give you a
high-level conclusion we are work
actually gives the first end-to-end
protocol to perform these kind of
genome-wide Association studies for
about 25,000 individuals we were able to
complete this entire protocol with about
three days of computation this might
seem like a lot but when you consider
typical scientific computations to just
get access to the data oftentimes takes
90 days or something like that
so when we are able to perform useful
scientific studies that are able to
identify genetic causes of certain
diseases computing in something like
three days is actually well within this
realm of reason so let high-level
takeaway that I want you to understand
from the first part of this talk is that
using modern cryptographic tools we can
actually enable useful computations
while protecting and maintaining in a
privacy of the individual genomes that
go into these kinds of computations
let me also emphasize here that I'm
really just using genomics as one
particular use case of the more general
paradigm in cryptography but very often
the techniques that we develop and use
here can actually be applied to very
general computations over private data
so you have scenarios for instance and
machine learning where in the IOT space
where you actually need to do
computations on private data many of our
techniques here can actually be useful
and I'm very happy to talk to you about
those if you're interested so in a
remaining time I have left I'm going to
do mystifying to show you some of the
magic that goes on in constructing these
cryptographic protocols how do we do
computations on private inputs and as
the one concrete
for that I'm going to give you is this
y'all's protocol for doing two party
computation this is a beautiful protocol
due to Andrew Young and it dates back
even to the 1980s so it's very
impressive that a lot of these protocols
and these ideas were really around since
the dawn of cryptography and today
they're actually being applicable and
useful for addressing a lot of the
privacy challenges we face today so
y'all squirtle call is a classic
protocol for two party computation
namely there are two computing parties
and they each have some private inputs
maybe we have two hospitals and these
are the vectors they hold are sort of
the vit rare variants that occur among
the patient's within that hospital and
their goal is like compute some joint
function on their private inputs such
that at the end of the computation the
only thing that is revealed to the two
hospitals is the results of the
computation and whatever can be inferred
from those results so the computation
itself is very leaky or reveals a lot of
information before as we should not be
performing those kinds of computations
but if we design the computation
carefully
we have blind a relative ease enablement
ISM that provides a valid privacy and
functionality trade-off we can actually
perform these computations without
revealing any additional information let
me now describe for you how this
protocol execution works typically we're
going to denote one of the parties as
the garb ler and one of them as the
evaluator the reasons where these names
will become clear subsequently in this
talk let me just note here the yells
protocol is also called a garbled
circuit protocol so if you're if you've
heard that name before
this is what it's referring to so in a
first step of the computation what we're
going to do is we're going to model that
computation as a boolean circuit so
we're going to express it as a sequence
of logic gates where the inputs to this
boolean circuit are the inputs of each
of the individual parties so some of the
wires here labeled in green are
pertaining to party one and it was some
that are labeled in orange are held by
party number two so the output of the
computation is going to be computed by
this digit or by this logic circuit and
the second step of the protocol now is
one of these designated parties namely
lagarde blur is going to essentially
prepare an encryption of the circuit or
a garbling of the circuit and it's going
to be done in a very special way to
enable to the evaluator the subsequent
that you learn the output of the
computation on
the input of its choosing the way it
works is as follows the gardener is
going to start by choosing two different
symmetric encryption keys for every wire
in the circuit right so each we have a
bunch of input wires we have
intermediate wires and then we have
output wires
so first the gardener is going to choose
two encryption keys for the first wire
of the circuit and it's going to proceed
like flies so every single wire in a
circuit has two different keys
associated with it why two keys well
essentially each key is going to be
associated with a particular value that
can be the value of that particular wire
right we're talking about boolean
circuits so that means all of the inputs
are binary values they're 0 1 values and
all of the intermediate wires as you
sort of evaluate each gate of a circuit
it's also a 0 1 value so each key can
essentially be associated with a 1
single wire value that's why we have to
vote keys for each wire one for the
value 0 for that wire 1 for the value 1
for that particular wire so now let me
describe for you how we actually encrypt
or garble each of the gates in the
circuit the protocol is going to precede
gate by gate so every gate is going to
be prepared as follows let's focus on
one particular gate and an gate first
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at the truth table for this and
gate so just to recall in a NAND gate
the output wire is 1 if and only if both
of the input wires are equal to 1 so on
the right half of the slide I've written
down the truth table of the and gate
where the inputs are contributed by
parties 1 & 2 and the output is just the
end of the two input bits now recall
that for every wire in the circuit I
have associated with them two different
keys okay so I'm going to just write
down the keys associated with the input
wires as well as the output wires and a
key idea now we're essentially going to
encrypt the output key with the two
input keys okay so let me show you this
as a picture let's take the first row in
this truth table so both the inputs are
0 the output is also 0 so what we're
going to do is we're going to encrypt
the key associated with the value 0 for
the output wire here denoted by K 0 out
and we're going to encrypt it using the
two keys corresponding to the input
values so parties Ones input value at 0
party
whose input value is also zero and we're
going to do proceed likewise so for
every row in the truth table we're going
to produce a ciphertext and the
ciphertext is going to be encrypted
using two different keys where the
choice of the two keys depends on the
corresponding values for those input
wires and now we're simply going to
shuffle the rows of this table randomly
okay so we're going to randomly permute
the ordering of the cipher text for each
garbled table now observe how do we do
evaluation what we're going to do is
we're going to somehow I haven't
explained how but give the evaluator
this garbled table as well as ensure
that the evaluator only has a single key
for every single input wire for the
circuit now notice that if the evaluator
has a single key for each wire it can be
crypt exactly one of the rows in this
table namely the row corresponding to
its particular input configuration in
this case the evaluator has the key for
the bit one for party ones input for the
green input and a bit zero for party
twos input so it is able to decrypt the
first row of this table so what that
looks like is the evaluator takes this
key it unlocks the first ciphertext and
then it unlocks the second component and
out pops the output key so if we ensure
that the evaluator has exactly one key
for every wire in the input layer the
construction of the garbling process
ensures that the evaluator can
essentially learn one key for every wire
in the intermediate circuit as well as
the output circuit and this is what
allows the evaluator to perform the
evaluation process notice that when the
evaluator obtains the output key the
output value this is just a random
symmetric key just another cryptographic
key it has no semantic meaning the key
itself does not say the value is zero so
essentially what the evaluator can do is
it obtains a new key but it doesn't
really know whether this key corresponds
to the value 0 or the value 1 and this
is how we're going to get privacy okay
so the overall protocol will roughly go
as follows the gardener is going to
prepare as garble circuits and it's
going to send the garbled tables as well
as the keys for its input to the
evaluator there's one more step that's
missing here how does the evaluator
obtain the keys for its input because
the evaluator also participates in the
computation
and needs to provide some set of keys in
order to actually decrypt the entries in
these garbled tables and compute their
responses but there's one final
ingredient which is the notion of an
oblivious Transfer Protocol I'm just
going to describe it abstractly here I'm
not going to give you the concrete
details but roughly what the setup is as
follows here we have agar blur the garb
ler chose two keys for every wire in the
circuit so for all of the wires that are
contributed by the other party by the
evaluator it has two keys but it doesn't
know which key to give to the evaluator
because that depends on the evaluators
input so what an oblivious transfer
protocol does is it enables the
evaluator to choose exactly one of the
two keys and in particular it allows it
to obtain a single key for its chosen
input so in this case if the evaluators
input is the value one it is going to
request the one key so an oblivious
product transfer protocol enables
precisely that computation it allows the
evaluator to obtain the key
corresponding to its input namely the
key one for this concrete example while
ensuring that the gobbler learns no
information about which key the
evaluator chose so in this way we can
actually implement and a secure
computation protocol for arbitrary
functionalities and as follows so in the
first round of the protocol the
evaluator is going to send an OT message
or an oblivious transfer message asking
for the keys corresponding to its input
and then the garbha is going to reply
with the garbled circuits it's going to
reply with the keys for its input and
then finally the responses to the
oblivious transfer query that enables
the evaluator to learn the keys for its
input we're revealing no additional
information to the garbha then the
evaluator can you simply use these keys
every time it has it has the keys for
the inputs they can obtain the key for
the output and it can proceed likewise
gate by gates through the circuit
eventually receiving the output this is
a very basic description of y'alls
protocol any ensuing 35 years since the
introduction of EOS protocol many
improvements have been proposed and
today this is actually as highly
efficient protocol for that enables many
different kinds of secure computation so
protocol is extremely efficient the main
bottleneck today is in terms of the
communication
so the unfortunate thing is that the
Garbo circuit can be very very big right
because if you think about it every
single gate in the circuit consists of
two ciphertex consists of a small number
of ciphertexts and this can quickly add
up depending on the magnitude and the
complexity of the computation of
interest but the evaluation time in the
garbling time is actually very fast
though just to come back to the original
picture I hope I sort of demystify what
some of what goes on in these
multi-party computation protocols so
using these kinds of protocols and these
kinds of tools we can actually enable
useful computations while retaining a
privacy of individual genomic data for
instance and our scenarios we oftentimes
represent the computation as a boolean
circuit and then we run an instantiation
of y'alls protocol for other scenarios
such as the large-scale genome wide
Association problem we use different
multi-party computation protocols and
these will vary depending on the nature
of the computation what kind of
protocols we would like to use to
achieve what kind of efficiency and
performance constraints so again as a
high-level picture I hope I've
demonstrated to you that using some of
these new kinds of cryptographic
techniques we can actually input perform
useful scientific computations while
preserving the privacy of the underlying
genomic data and to conclude if you're
interested in learning more our papers
available was published in science
earlier last year we have a complete
implementation if you're interested in
exploring and playing around with the
code and there will be an upcoming paper
appearing in nature biotech hopefully
this month or next month on doing the
large-scale privacy-preserving
genome-wide Association studies thank
you very much
I have to say that David is my first
student to actually graduated with
papers and science and biotech does it
require that every party defect or what
like what's the guarantees on a number
of the factors you tolerate right so in
all of these protocols we work in this
so-called to cloud scenario where all of
the parties are secret shared they their
data to these two cloud servers and
they're trusted not to collude so it's
possible that one of the Klaus is
malicious but as long as they're not
sharing their data than where we have
security right and certainly and
coupling works we're trying to relax
that model and get stronger as security
but it is for the first step for the
second parts of the genome-wide
Association study did you just use a
secure multi-party computation or also
differential privacy and if so how do
these two methods right it's an
excellent question so for the focus of
this work we were looking at primarily
cryptographic solutions so there's been
a lot of other work also by the same lab
at MIT so Bonnie burgers group does a
lot of work on this looking at using
differential privacy techniques also for
it to you want so these provide
different kinds of trade-offs and I
think one of the nice things about it is
that differential privacy is also very
compatible with the cryptographic
framework so we can add noise either at
the beginning or at the end of the
computations in order to also implement
a differential privacy mechanism on top
of the cryptography so these are not
mutually exclusive and they provide
different kinds of security guarantees
so for G was I think differential
privacy and crypto both are valid tools
for the first task of doing these rare
disease diagnosis differential privacy
is less suitable because we often have
very small number of patients and we're
really looking for those rare events
well well so these techniques themselves
are very general so in principle we can
do arbitrary computations the question
is what kind of computations can we do
efficiently and there I think we need a
lot of more communication between sort
at least for the genomic space between
the computational biologists who sort of
propose the kinds of computations they
would like to do and the cryptographers
sort of saying what kind of computations
can we do efficiently and I think the
most interesting research is sort of
finding that interesting middle ground
where we can do useful scientific
computations but also at a scale that
enables useful scientific discoveries
thank you
[Applause]